chargé élaboré un texte sur les
dispositions restent en discussion de la
proposition de loi visant à renforcer
l'accompagnement des cellules locaux
dans la mise en oeuvre de la lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Baptiste
BLANC rapporteur pour le Sénat de la
commission pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale les mes chers collègues jeudi
dernier nous sommes parvenus un accord
avec nos collègues députés en commission
mixte paritaire sur la proposition de
loi visant à faciliter la mise en oeuvre
des objectifs de zéro artificialisation
nette au cœur des territoires
l'assemblée a on a adopté les
conclusions hier nous pouvons nous fait
féliciter de cette aboutissement trouver
un accord vous le savez n'a pas été sans
mal je ne travaillais aucun secret en
vous disant que cette CMP a bien failli
ne pas aboutir mais même avant cette CMP
le chemin de cette TPL a été semé
d'embûches nous avons dû faire bien des
compromis pour le porter enfin sur les
fronts je voudrais ici remercier la
présidente Valérie léthard et saluer son
engagement et son extrême ténacité
sur ce dossier
à travers vous tous les membres de la
commission spéciale qui sont tous toutes
et tous impliqués très très fortement et
je pense que les territoires leur
doivent beaucoup à vos côtés chers
Valérie cette proposition de loi ne
l'avons en effet tous portés ensemble
dans un esprit transpartisan au sein
d'abord de la mission conjointe de
contrôle qui a débouché sur sa rédaction
puis au sein de la commission spéciale
qu'il a instruite l'intérêt des
territoires a toujours été notre unique
boussole après l'adoption de notre PPL
au Sénat en mars dernier nous avons dû
batailler pour obtenir son inscription à
l'ordre du jour à l'Assemblée puis pour
obtenir la garantie d'un temps suffisant
pour son examen en séance publique pour
ce faire le ministre Christophe Béchu
nous a fait nous a fait une proposition
au début perçu comme original peut-être
baroque mais soit c'est à dire faire
passer la moitié des articles par la
voix réglementaire alors sachant que
nous étions quelque peu échaudés par les
décrets précédemment vous voyez bon ce
que nous avons dû apprécier comme
situation madame la ministre j'aimerais
que nous mesurions ce que cela signifie
cela signifie demander au législateur de
se dessaisir volontairement de son
pouvoir au profit du pouvoir
réglementaire et pourtant après des
échanges nourris avec vous avec Monsieur
le Ministre Béchu avec nos collègues de
la commission spéciale ben nous avons
accepté et ce faisant nous avons fait le
choix de la responsabilité et de la
confiance nous avons fait le choix de la
fameuse co-construction premier point la
responsabilité parce que les élus
attendent les outils créés par cette PPL
la garantie communale de développement
le droit de préemption élargi le sursis
est situé la comptabilisation à part des
grands projets personne n'aurait compris
que nous n'explorions pas toutes les
voies possibles pour faire aboutir cette
PPL deuxième point la confiance c'est un
véritable travail partenarial je le
disais qui a été mené avec les services
de votre ministère pour rédiger les
décrets
vraiment des dispositions aussi
essentielles de notre texte que la non
prescritivité prescritive du sera dette
la prise en compte des efforts passés ou
le traitement de la nomenclature dans la
nomenclature d'usane des jardins
pavillères les associations d'élus ont
été aussi constamment associés à tout
cela bien évidemment les décrire ont été
mises en consultation publique le 13
juin dernier ils seront examinés par le
CNN la semaine prochaine nous
continuerons bien sûr être extrêmement
vigilant sur leur contenu jusqu'à leur
publication finale il en va de même pour
le décret sur la commission de
conciliation
introduite en CMP à l'article 4 pour
régler les différentes l'État et les
collectivités sur les grands projets
au-delà de leur publications nous serons
attentifs nous et nos successeurs
évidemment à ce que c'est décret ne
soient pas dans un avenir proche la
première variable d'ajustement des
imperfections de la loi qui m'a
résilience il ne faudrait pas qu'à la
première alerte sur la trajectoire de
réduction de l'artificialisation on
revienne par exemple sur la non
prescriptibilité du stradet nous avons
toujours dit que l'accord doit être
globale un accord législativement
réglementaire en quelque sorte à la
première alerte sur les décrets nous
rouvrirons le chantier législatif madame
la ministre j'en viens maintenant au
détail de ce texte que nous avons adopté
en CMP nous avons préservé des points
essentiels nous avons obtenu le report
de la modification des documents de
planification d'urbanisme nous avons
préservé le rôle central des
collectivités dans la mise en oeuvre et
la gouvernance du zan d'abord grâce à la
création dans chaque région d'une
conférence du zan qui rassemblera les
élus locaux en matière d'urbanisme avec
des représentants des régions et des
services de l'État pour piloter de
manière coordonnées la mise en oeuvre du
zan ensuite en donnant aux régions après
consultation de cette conférence le
droit de proposer des projets
d'envergure national d'en accepter la
liste nous avons redonné des marges
manoeuvre aux élus locaux avec le sursis
actuel droit de préemption élargie la
prise en compte de la renaturation dès
2021 et enfin nous avons desserré la
contrainte du zan sur les territoires
grâce à la garantie communale dont nous
avons pu rétablir l'universalité et la
comptabilisation
obligatoire des grands projets il y aura
certes pas d'exclusion pure et simple de
l'ensemble ces grands projets je sais
que certains d'entre vous le regrettent
mais un bon compromis n'est-ce pas quand
tout le monde est mécontent selon la
formule bien connue retenons que nous
avons inscrit dans la loi que
l'artificialisation induite par les
grands projets ne serait pas imputés aux
collectivités d'implantation retenons
que nous avons inscrit dans la loi noir
sur blanc que la mutualisation sera
limitée à 10 000 hectares par zone de
plus ce texte maintenant il va falloir
le faire vivre il va falloir beaucoup de
pédagogie auprès de nos élus pour qu'ils
puissent s'en emparer pleinement et
s'emparer pleinement de ces nouveaux
outils ils auront besoin aussi d'autres
outils financiers notamment pour
réhabiliter les friches mais aussi pour
donner son juste prix aux foncier la
fiscalité sera un levier nous le savons
toutes et tous et ce sera notre prochain
chantier je vous remercie merci chers
collègues
la parole est à Madame Dominique Faure
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
monsieur le Président Madame la
Présidente l'état monsieur le rapporteur
blanc mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices je suis très
heureuse de vous retrouver aujourd'hui
en hémicycle pour le vote de des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire de la proposition de loi
visant à faciliter la mise en œuvre des
objectifs de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols et à
renforcer l'accompagnement des élus
locaux je vous prie de bien vouloir
excuser Christophe bechut qui a défendu
ce texte au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
nationale il est retenu tout simplement
en conseil des ministres pour présenter
le projet de loi d'urgence relatif à
l'accélération de la reconstruction des
bâtiments dégradés ou démolis au cours
des émeutes
projet de loi d'urgence que vous aurez
l'occasion d'examiner la semaine
prochaine la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols comme vous
le savez et décisive pour limiter
l'empreinte environnementale de notre
société alors tout d'abord car un seul
artificialisé ne stocke plus de CO2
ensuite car en stock un seul
artificialisé est un espace stérile pour
notre biodiversité enfin car un sol
artificialisé
imperméable contribue directement et
massivement au dérèglement du cycle de
l'eau une perturbation que nous vivons
un peu plus durement chaque année
depuis 1981 les terres artificialisées
seraient passées de 3 millions
d'hectares à 5,1 millions d'hectares
avec une croissance nettement supérieure
à celle de notre population
tout d'abord le zan une réponse
indispensable à l'urgence de lutter
contre l'artificialisation des sols dont
il faut préserver la trajectoire tout en
facilitant sa territorialisation par le
dialogue cet objectif de 0
artificialisation nette
face à cette urgence et pour mettre un
terme à ce cercle vicieux le Parlement a
adopter la trajectoire zan dans le cadre
de la loi climat et résilience à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat et
cela cet engagement il est double à la
fois diminué par deux la consommation
d'espace naturel agricoles et forestiers
les Hénaf sur la décennie 2021 2031 par
rapport à la décennie passée
2011-2021 concrètement cela revient à
prolonger la baisse déjà observée de la
consommation d'espace naturel avec un
effort supplémentaire permettant de
tenir un objectif moyen de consommation
de 12500 hectares par an jusqu'en 2031
en cela je souligne que la loi n'a pas
créé une rupture dans les pratiques
d'aménagement elle ne fait qu'amplifier
la tendance et demande un effort
supplémentaire au territoire mais un
effort limité ensuite la marge d'après
c'est de parvenir à un usage des sols de
0 artificialisation nette à horizon 2050
concrètement cela revient à faire le
solde entre les surfaces nouvellement
artificialisées et les surfaces rendus à
la nature dans cette démarche nous ne
sommes pas seuls et bon nombre de nos
partenaires européens ont d'ores et déjà
adopter des mesures
pardon
en dehors c'est déjà adopté des mesures
pour limiter progressivement
l'artificialisation des sols dans la
continuité des recommandations de la
commission l'horizon fils fixé au niveau
européen est également celui du 0
artificialisation net à horizon 2050
notre objectif constant depuis le début
c'est donc d'une part de garantir
l'application et le respect de cette
trajectoire à la fois parce qu'elle est
indispensable et parce qu'elle est issue
d'un vote de la représentation nationale
d'autre part de privilégier toujours le
dialogue et la concertation avec les
élus locaux pour sa mise en oeuvre
territorialisée c'est l'esprit suivi par
le gouvernement depuis le début sur ce
texte et qui a prévalu dans le cadre du
compromis trouvé en commission mixte
paritaire
deuxièmement la construction d'un chemin
de consensus en commission mixte
paritaire la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui a fait l'objet de
longs débat plus de 13 heures d'examens
en hémicycle au Sénat plus de 15 heures
à l'Assemblée nationale et plus de 6
heures en commission mixte paritaire un
chemin de consensus c'est cependant
dessiner au cours de ces échanges
nourrit également de nombreux échanges
avec les associations d'élus comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le rapporteur la
proposition de loi contient ainsi des
mesures de bon sens de facilitation avec
lesquelles nous sommes en accord depuis
le début tout d'abord la prise en compte
de la renaturation avant 2031 ensuite la
mise en place de nouveaux outils comme
les communes pour les communes pour
mieux maîtriser les projets avant 2031
avec la mise en place d'un droit de
préemption élargi pour les communes et
d'un mécanisme de sursis à statuer
spécifique encore la possibilité offerte
aux communes littoral d'anticiper le
recul du trait de côte dans la
recomposition
urbaine qui induit
il est ensuite des dispositions dont
nous rejoignons l'esprit mais qui
relevait du domaine réglementaire je
pense notamment en lien juridique entre
les différents documents d'urbanisme à
la prise en compte des efforts passés ou
des spécificités des différents
territoires ou encore des dispositions
relatives à la nomenclature de
l'artificialisation ces dispositions ont
été retranscrites dans la réécriture des
décrets du 29 avril 2022 ils sont
actuellement soumis à la consultation du
public
enfin nous étions au niveau du
gouvernement attaché à deux grands
principes dans la continuité des
annonces faites par la première ministre
lors du dernier congrès de l'Association
des maires de France tout d'abord la
prise en compte des communes les plus
petites avec le principe d'une garantie
rurale le compromis trouvé en commission
mixte paritaire préserve la garantie à
un hectare souhaité par le Sénat et
permet à toutes les communes de
bénéficier de ce minimum qu'elle soit
couverte par un PLU un PLU ou une carte
communale les communes ont également la
possibilité de prescrire un document
d'urbanisme avant le 1er août 2026 si
elle souhaite bénéficier de la garantie
rurale ensuite la prise en compte des
villes les plus grandes avec les grands
projets d'envergure national un
consensus a été trouvé sur le fait que
certains grands projets de l'État par
exemple des infrastructures majeures
telles que les lignes à grande vitesse
ou le canal senor Europe cons beaucoup
d'espace à l'échelle d'une région il
doit faire l'objet d'une prise en compte
spécifique sans que cela ne remette en
cause de l'objectif de réduction de 50%
de la consommation d'espace naturel
agricoles et forestiers fixés pour 2031
ce compromis trouvé en commission mixte
permet que la liste des grands projets
restent définis après consultation par
l'État tout en prévoyant un droit de
proposition des régions un forfait de
12500 hectares est prévu dont 12000
pardon dans 10 000 seront mutualisés
entre les régions couvertes par un
stradette
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs le
texte issu de nos débats est bien un
texte de compromis qui permet d'adapter
les dispositions de la loi climat et
résilience aux réalités des territoires
sans revenir pour autant sur les
objectifs et la trajectoire que nous
étions collectivement fixés en 2021 je
souhaite que nous puissions aujourd'hui
adopter un texte qui fasse consensus qui
permettent une meilleure appropriation
de l'objectif de réduction de
l'artificialisation dans les territoires
conditions essentielles à son efficacité
je sais par ailleurs que nous aurons
l'occasion de nous revoir pour parler de
sujets directement en lien avec notre
trajectoire de réduction et
d'artificialisation de nos sols l'État
devra être au rendez-vous et sera au
rendez-vous pour accompagner les
collectivités territoriales notamment
les plus petites d'entre elles en
matière d'ingénierie
nous devons également comme le souligne
l'article 15 du texte sur lequel nous
votons aujourd'hui poursuivre la
réflexion approfondie qui est en cours
sur la fiscalité comme outil de lutte
contre l'artificialisation des sols la
transition écologique est un véritable
défi pour nous tous qui mérite bien que
l'on dépasse les clivages au service des
Françaises et des Français je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre je
rappelle qu'en application d'article 42
alinéa 12 du règlement le Sénat
examinant après l'Assemblée nationale
Tex élaborée par la commission
explorateur et se prononce par un seul
vote sur l'ensemble du texte en ne
retenant que les amendements présentés
ou acceptés par le gouvernement
conséquence le vote sur les amendements
et sur les articles et réservé nous
passons à présentation des amendements
du Gouvernement sur la proposition de
loi avant d'en venir aux explications de
vote des groupes madame la ministre si
vous pouvez nous présenter les
amendements
parfait donc nous passons aux
explications de votre dégroupe à raison
d'un orateur par groupe monsieur
Jean-Claude Anglard pour les
républicains pour 5 minutes
merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre madame la Présidente
la commission spéciale monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues le vote
d'aujourd'hui et le résultat d'un long
processus où la seule constance aura été
celle du Sénat qui a toujours eu pour
objectif d'agir en faveur d'une mise en
œuvre pragmatique et réaliste du zan
sans idéologie
rapidement après l'entrée en vigueur de
la loi climat résilience du 22 août 2021
ces difficultés ont été constatées les
communes n'étaient pas suffisamment
associées et le calendrier prévu était
trop contraint la publication des décrit
l'application de la loi climat et
résilience contraire déjà à l'accord qui
avait été trouvé à l'époque a été
particulièrement problématique la
situation menée à une impasse en raison
de la crainte d'une aggravation des
inégalités territoriales et du besoin de
dialogue entre les différents et selon
territoriaux la proposition de loi que
j'avais déposée dès le mois de décembre
2021 ensuite celle de Philippe Bas ont
initié la réponse législative la
réflexion a été ensuite enrichie par la
consultation en ligne des élus locaux
réalisés par la commission des affaires
économiques ainsi que par les travaux du
groupe ruralité mené par Jean-Marc Boyer
Daniel Laurent et Anne vantalon
enfin la mission conjointe de contrôle
créée en cette fin septembre 2022
présidée avec talent et discernement par
Valérie Letard je salue à formaliser
l'engagement du Sénat à mener une
réforme transpartisane de la mise en
oeuvre du zones après de nombreuses
auditions et autant de déplacements du
rapporteur Jean-Baptiste blanc dont je
salue l'engagement sur le sujet
et des membres de la commission une
proposition de loi visant à faciliter la
mise en oeuvre des objectifs de 0
artificialisé sur le net au cœur des
territoires a été déposé et examinée au
mois de mars 2023
à l'issue de la navette parlementaire et
de la réunion de la CMP qui a été
difficile de nombreux apports de la
proposition de loi sénatoriale sont
conservées
en ce sens nous pouvons être satisfaits
de la mutualisation entre région de
l'artificialisation induite par de
grands projets nationaux dans un forfait
rabaissé à 10 000 hectares et la sortie
des surfaces artificialisée au-delà de
ce seuil
il en est de la même de même de la
création du droit à projet via une
garantie rurale de 1 ha pour l'ensemble
des communes sans condition de densité
ainsi que la création d'un droit de
préemption urbain élargit au fin de
renaturation les maires disposeront
ainsi de 6 mois supplémentaires pour
inscrire des objectifs du zan dans les
documents d'urbanisme locaux la mise en
œuvre sera donc facilité par les apports
du Sénat reste un point essentiel qui
fait aujourd'hui défaut l'accord trouve
un CMP prévoyait d'exclure les bâtiments
agricoles des surfaces artificialisées
cette disposition était présente dans la
propulsion de loi du Sénat suite à
l'amendement que j'avais déposé et qui
avait été adoptée avant d'être supprimé
à l'Assemblée nationale le futur décret
d'application devait permettre
d'atteindre cet objectif avec une
rédaction sans ambiguïté or au regard
des informations dont nous disposons
n'est-ce pas et malgré le fait que nous
ayons exprimé nos fortes réserves sur la
rédaction envisagées par le gouvernement
le risque de que ces bâtiments soient
comptabilisés à terme dans le existe
toujours pour quelle raison est-ce le
choix du ministre ou est-ce le choix de
l'Ouest l'administration qui a décidé
ainsi et qu'en pense le ministre de
l'Agriculture ce sont des questions que
nous posons en tout cas le gouvernement
sera seul responsable de ce comporter à
nos agriculteurs et à l'agriculture si
vous ne respectez pas votre engagement
la position du groupe en tout cas les
républicains sur ce texte et donc très
simple
considérant d'une part les longs
processus engagés et d'autre part
l'urgence à agir pour aider les élus
locaux nous voterons en faveur du texte
ce vote n'est pas un satisfaisible pour
le gouvernement car nous ne partageons
pas la vision qui est la vôtre d'une
France agricole sous cloche
notre vote vient valider le travail
engagé par le Sénat pour aider les élus
locaux dans la mise en oeuvre du zones
nous serons vigilants concernant
l'ensemble des futurs décrets
d'applications et attentif aux nouvelles
difficultés qui surviendront dans les
prochaines années notamment pour le
bâtiment agricoles je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Monsieur Emmanuel Capu
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
l'objectif de sobriété foncière fait
heureusement aujourd'hui qu'on s'insus
cependant fin juin 2021 notre collègue
Pierre melviel alors orateur du groupe
Les Indépendants lors des explications
de votre concernant le projet de loi
climat et résilience avec déjà
clairement traduit les inquiétudes de
certains sur la stratégie nationale de
lutte contre l'artificialisation des
sols il indiquait nous imaginons à peine
les contraintes que ce texte risque de
faire peser sur le développement de nos
territoires plus particulièrement ruraux
dans les années à venir
le groupe Les Indépendants avaient
d'ailleurs
identifié les problèmes qui se cachaient
sous l'important besoin de réduire notre
consommation des sols qui n'est plus
contestée par personne nous avions alors
élaboré des amendements afin de mieux
équilibrer cette politique et de la
rendre plus juste entre nos territoires
l'impératif que nous nous sommes fixés
depuis le début de la mise en place de
la mission conjointe de contrôle en
charge notamment de formuler des pistes
d'évolution concrètes du cadre juridique
de la mise en oeuvre du zan est assez
simple trouver une ligne de crête un
consensus
le but n'est pas à la remise en cause
des objectifs de lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols mais bien
d'aider les élus locaux ainsi qu'il est
services de l'État sur nos territoires à
les mettre en pratique une mise en
pratique réaliste ou aucun territoire ni
d'aucun ni aucun document d'urbanisme ne
prend le pas sur l'autre ou le National
le régional et le local trouvent un
équilibre et où il n'y a pas
d'opposition entre le rural et l'urbain
oui chers collègues c'était plutôt
complexe quel que soit le sens dans
lequel on le formulait c'est pourquoi
j'aimerais d'abord et encore une fois
saluer le travail qui a été effectué au
Sénat sur ce sujet par la présidente de
la commission spéciale va élary Letard
par le rapporteur Jean-Baptiste blanc et
par tous les membres de la mission puis
de la commission spéciale nous avons
défendu nos positions et nous avons
obtenu des résultats nos convictions
sont claires au service de nos
territoires de nos élus et surtout des
Français je connais aussi
particulièrement bien l'engagement du
ministre Béchu dont l'écoute la
connaissance de cette maison et du
dossier ont permis de trouver un terrain
d'entente qui je crois nous permettra
d'avancer je salue bien évidemment la
ministre fort qui est aujourd'hui au
bord
le texte que nous votons accompagné de
mesures réglementaires revues également
par nous-mêmes contient des
améliorations significatives à
l'application d'usaz au sein de la
Chambre des territoires il était
important de tout faire pour faciliter
la vie de nos élus locaux qui vont
devoir appliquer cette politique nous
connaissons tous la difficulté de leur
tâches notamment en ces temps de
transition
concrètement le texte issu de la CMP
prévoit des avancées notables dans
l'ordre des articles du texte les élus
auront plus de temps pour adapter les
stradettes ainsi que tous les autres
documents d'urbanisme à l'objectif du
âmes la conférence régionale et sa
composition précisée seront des atouts
dans la mise en place d'une réelle
gouvernance décentralisée l'enjeu
certainement le plus important alors que
nous avons dédié nos discussions du mois
dernier à l'industrie verte était la
sortie de certains projets d'envergure
et d'envergure nationale et européenne
des enveloppes locales je me félicite
particulièrement du fait que les projets
industriels d'intérêt majeur pour
souveraineté de la nation ou la
transition écologique face partie de ces
projets d'envergure il est important
qu'on ne bloque pas des projets
importants pour nos territoires je pense
sur mon territoire à des projets comme
celui de l'AS dans chez moi
projette d'extension d'une usine de
valorisation énergétique à Noyant
village ce genre d'entreprises
vertueuses au carrefour de la transition
écologique et de la transition
énergétique doit être encouragée et non
pas entravé il est crucial que de tels
puissent continuer à sortir de terre au
service de la population je précise que
noyant village comme beaucoup de
communes dans le Maine-et-Loire est une
commune nouvelle ce qui me permet de
saluer la garantie rurale qui est
accordée à toutes les communes et
particulièrement
aux communes nouvelle puisqu'elle est
valorisée dans le cadre des communes
déléguées
c'est une mesure de bon sens rassurante
pour les territoires le temps imparti
n'étant pas suffisant pour tout
développer
je préciserai juste je valoriserai juste
le droit de préemption urbain qui me
paraît le bienvenu tout comme la prise
en compte des efforts passés des
spécificités des territoires de montagne
et de se soumis à la loi littorale nous
sommes tous conscients mes chers
collègues que le chemin est encore long
que les complications et difficultés ne
sont pas derrière nous mais bien au
contraire devant nous et nous savons
aussi ce qui est proposé que ce qui est
proposé représente un équilibre qui
n'existe pas dans le droit actuel c'est
la raison pour laquelle les indépendants
vendront ce texte sans difficulté
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur renaudantec pour le groupe
écologiste solidarité territoire pour 5
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur madame la
Présidente nous avons eu l'occasion de
le souligner lors des débats précédents
réduire puis stopper l'artificialisation
de nos sols est une véritable priorité
écologique et économique écologique car
rappelle des espaces naturels agricoles
et forestiers les fameux Hénaf et une
des raisons majeures de la perte de
biodiversité et de la réduction de nos
capacités de stockage de CO2 économique
tout autant car l'artificialisation des
espaces agricoles réduit d'autant notre
capacité de production alimentaire il me
semble donc que tous les défenseurs de
la ferme France il y en a dans cette
hémicycle tous ceux qui craignent la
perte d'autonomie alimentaire de la
France et de l'Europe devrait être en
première ligne pour défendre le zinc
voir se mobiliser pour accélérer la mise
en œuvre
Lausanne était une des propositions de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
c'est de fait une des rares mesures
ambitieuses qui a trouvé une
concrétisation forte dans la loi le sans
filtre initial c'est quand même
transformé en un tamis aux mailles
serrées où se sont coincés bien d'autres
propositions Lausanne est un objectif
ambitieux mais la loi puis les premiers
décrets d'application n'avaient pas
toujours pris en compte la complexité de
sa mise en oeuvre dans les territoires
en proposant une loi complémentaire le
Sénat faisait œuvre utile et a permis de
préciser ou de revoir certains
dispositifs initiaux assez
problématiques et je remercie donc
évidemment la présidente Valérie d'État
et leur rapporteur Jean-Baptiste blanc
pour leur engagement et leur travail
mais de l'amélioration au détricotage il
n'y a parfois que des différences de
virgules et le débat au Sénat a conduit
au vote d'amendement et de dispositions
qui remettaient clairement en cause
l'objectif lui-même au risque même que
le ministre Christophe Béchu on perde
son cal un pierres naturels on sent raté
au sortir du Sénat ce sont donc des
dizaines de milliers d'hectares qui
n'étaient plus comptabilisés nulle part
dans une large enveloppe où se trouvait
des projets nationaux ou internationaux
et les pelouses des pavillons
individuels n'étaient même plus
considérés comme artificialisé à partir
de 2031 ce qui reste une aberration
totale
l'Assemblée nationale a donc chers
collègues je suis désolé de le dire
plutôt améliorer le texte en remettant
quelques cadres bienvenue mais en
renvoyant aussi beaucoup d'éléments à de
futurs décrets cela a été dit si on
résume le texte nous retrouvons donc
dans les points positifs grâce au Sénat
la création d'une enveloppe nationale
qui était absolument nécessaire pour ne
pas tout faire peser sur les communes
l'Assemblée nationale a donc
opportunément remutualisé sur les
régions il resterait néanmoins madame
lemise pour que tout le monde soit
rassuré à ce que l'État se donne aussi
comme contraint de ne pas dépasser les
12500 hectares dans la prochaine période
en étant donc en capacité de
hiérarchiser ses propres projets
d'artificialisation nous retrouvons
aussi un calendrier d'applications plus
resserré après le passage à l'Assemblée
nationale il y a quand même
urgence et je me permets de souligner au
final cher Jean-Baptiste que la
proposition retenue comme un assez
proche de mon amendement de compromis
c'est-à-dire on garde un temps long sur
austradet et on réduit l'étoile
administratives sur le Scott et le plus
on aurait pu le voter au Sénat
directement la garantie rurale devenue
communale aura provoqué bien des débats
laissez un peu de marge aux communes 100
ans à un moment où les élus locaux ont
le sentiment d'être dépossédés de leur
capacité de projet néanmoins j'entends
par exemple le scepticisme de la
Fédération des scottes sur cette
proposition ne revenons pas en arrière
l'aménagement du territoire ne se
construit pas à l'échelle communale la
somme des intérêts communaux ne fait pas
non plus l'intérêt général et le sens de
l'histoire la seule manière de tenir
tous nos grands objectifs sur le
logement ou le climat c'est la
robustesse et des scottes une réelle
planification territoriale d'où
l'importance de la prescrivabilité
prescriptibilité d'estradettes c'est un
de nos points de désaccord enfin
l'article 9 reste sujet à bien des
interprétations et la nomenclature qui
se dessine n'est toujours pas très clair
à ce stand tout comme moi j'ai pas tout
compris sortir les pelouses avec 25% de
plantation du décompte serait la porte
ouverte à tous les contournements
j'aimerais sur ce point madame la
ministre quelques éclaircissements j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour dire qu'il y a à
mon avis une erreur initiale dans la loi
en changeant à partir de 2031 la
nomenclature il aurait mieux valu
conserver la logique de préservation des
Hénaf qui est le vrai enjeu et ne pas
chercher à inventer une autre manière de
comptabiliser à partir de 2031 avec
d'ores et déjà des confusions entre
artificialisation et imperméabilisation
de plus donc dans ce texte des plus et
des mois et surtout beaucoup de points
renvoyés à des craies en restant
vigilant très vigilant sur ce point le
groupe écologiste s'abstiendra donc pas
prudence sur les conclusions de la CMP
merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Ludovic est
pour le groupe RDP pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
spéciale monsieur le rapporteur mais
chers collègues nous voici arrivés au
bout d'un long processus législatif qui
débouche sur un accord acceptable pour
tous c'est surtout un accord
utile aux élus locaux la commission
mixte paritaire a fait l'objet d'un long
débat et nous avons su trouver une voie
de compromis un équilibre très attendu
dans nos territoires la lutte contre
l'artifisation des sols est un combat
amené pour nos territoires et dans nos
territoires si demain nous ne tenons pas
nos objectifs ce sont eux qui ont
subiront les conséquences en matière
environnementale notamment je pense à
l'amplification des risques d'inondation
qui dans de nombreuses communes obligera
à des adaptations radicales dans les
décennies à venir
par ailleurs l'artificialisation
consomme les espaces naturels agricoles
et forestiers alors que la captation de
carbone est un des enjeux essentiels
justement pour la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique et surtout que
le renforcement de la souveraineté
agricole et alimentaire de notre pays
est plus que jamais une nécessité vitale
la guerre en Ukraine la volonté la
volatilité des marchés des matières
premières agricoles les multiplications
d'événements climatiques et leurs
conséquences à l'échelle mondiale sur
les récoltes nous rappelle l'importance
de ne pas dépendre des importations et
de l'urgence de renforcer notre
souveraineté agricole et cette dernière
est bien évidemment fondée avant toute
chose sur la disponibilité et la qualité
de nos sols et de savoir-faire nos
agriculteurs que je tiens ici à
souligner
porter au sein du plan biodiversité de
2018 puis au sein de la convention
citoyenne et dans le projet de loi
climat et résilience la lutte contre
l'artificialisation des sols exige une
approche territorialisée et pragmatique
car si les des personnes qui connaissent
précisément leur territoire et leur
possibilité de développement se sont
bien nos élus locaux
le cheminement de ce texte démontre que
des solutions communes permet de
satisfaire à cette exigence et elles
existent il faut ici rappeler qu'il
n'existe pas une une ruralité monotique
mais bien une diversité de ruralité et
qu'aucun texte ne pourrait satisfaire
parfaitement l'ensemble des parties
prenantes l'honneur du Parlement est de
trouver le plus petit dénominateur
commun et c'est ici chose faite le
gouvernement a été particulièrement à
l'écoute des élus locaux et des
parlementaires et je tiens ici à le
saluer et je remercie les ministres
concernés mais dans la misstre ici Auban
aujourd'hui pour le temps et le travail
qui nous ont consacré à intégrer les
remontées de terrain afin d'adapter en
conséquence la mise en oeuvre de la
stratégie 0 artificialisation nette
il nous apparaît que ce contexte permet
effectivement une souplesse
d'application de la stratégie zan sans
opérer notre capacité à atteindre nos
objectifs et garantit la possibilité
d'un développement de nos territoires je
pense à la garantie rurale et la
possibilité de mutualisation offerte aux
communes afin de penser l'aménagement du
territoire en bassin de vie le compromis
trouvé sur les grands projets nous
apportaient il s'agit du point qui a le
plus mobilisé nos collègues en
commission mixte paritaire en effet la
France est un tournant du 21e siècle et
les grands projets structurants du
territoire national ne doivent ni être
entrées par des difficultés d'accès aux
fonciers ni bloquer les plus petits
projets tout aussi essentiels le
compromis adopté offre une visibilité
aux élus locaux et aux porteurs de
projets sans renoncer à notre ambition
les positions préalablement antagonistes
sur ce dossier ont su évolué je le salue
et je me réjouis que nous ayons pu
aboutir un accord en la matière le
forfait national concilie les
injonctions parfois contradictoires
oires par ailleurs nous avons su aboutir
sur les délais de modification des
documents d'urbanisme sur les
spécificités des communes littérales et
sur la prise en compte des efforts de
renaturation
un message que je passe il nous faudra
quand même cependant ne pas laisser au
bord du chemin les communes qui se sont
engagées dans la mise en conformité de
leurs documents d'urbanisme et qu'il
nous faudra aider nous avons également
simplifié la conférence régionale
d'usane afin d'en faire une véritable
instance de gouvernance locale en
matière d'artifisation
d'artificialisation vous le savez
également une partie du texte
initialement adopté au Sénat sera mise
en oeuvre par la voie réglementaire
permettant à un gain de temps important
et témoignant de la bonne volonté du
gouvernement pour adapter la mise en
oeuvre de la stratégie zan mes chers
collègues nous avons su dépasser nos
divergences parfois très profondes et le
texte de consensus qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui nous rassemble pour le pour
accompagner nos élus locaux c'est
pourquoi notre groupe RDPI votera en
faveur de ce texte je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
la parole à Monsieur Christian Redon
Sarrasi pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste républicain pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur depuis deux ans notre
assemblée c'est particulièrement investi
pour répondre aux préoccupations des
élus locaux concernant cette mise en
oeuvre de l'objectif de zéro
artificialisation nette imposée il faut
le rappeler par l'adoption de la loi
climat et résilience en août 2021
la difficulté d'articuler les objectifs
de sobriété française
suscite en effet de nombreuses craintes
notamment dans les zones rurales qui
redoutent d'être freinées dans leur
projet de développement quatre axes
principaux cristallisés ainsi leurs
inquiétudes les outils permettant de
respecter le calendrier imposé et de
freiner des projets très consommateurs
d'espace la juste répartition de
l'effort de réduction de
l'artificialisation entre les
territoires l'Association des communes à
l'élaboration des schémas d'aménagement
régionaux et enfin la place des grands
projets dans le décompte global le texte
porté et adopté par le Sénat le 16 mars
dernier à trouver une issue favorable
lors de la CMP qui s'est tenu le 6
juillet après plusieurs heures de débat
entre les deux assemblées et le
gouvernement preuve que les arbitrages
n'avaient rien d'évident le Sénat néanmo
est tenu bon pour faire entendre la voix
les territoires et apporter les besoins
de clarification et d'appui demander par
les élus locaux
durant les négociations de ces derniers
mois le groupe socialiste c'est
particulièrement attaché à rétablir
l'équité entre les territoires à mieux
faire respecter les particularités et
les contraintes locales et à ramener
l'apaisement dans la mise en oeuvre de
cette réforme d'ampleur et structurantes
pour l'avenir de nos territoires cette
PPL comporte 80C majeures en premier
lieu redonner afin de redonner du temps
aux collectivités pour engager cette
réforme et permettre une meilleure
compréhension des enjeux par les
citoyens nous avions souhaité le report
des dates d'entrée en vigueur des
radettes et des documents d'urbanisme
infra nous avons obtenu une entrée
vigueur du stradet au plus tard le 29
novembre 2024 soit 9 mois de plus de
concertation les scottes devront être
mis en conformité au plus tard en
février 2027 les PLU et les cartes
communales en février 2028
en second lieu conformément à la
proposition initiale du Sénat le
dialogue territorial sera renforcé par
l'entremise d'une conférence régionale
de gouvernance design qui restera
composé principalement des lieux locaux
régionaux ONG et associations seront
consultés au titre des personnes
publiques associées pour un
particulièrement sensible la garantie
rurale de un hectare qui doit permettre
à toutes les petites communes de
dessiner les perspectives pour leur
propre développement et préserver
étendus ainsi aucune commune n'en sera
exclue qu'elle soit couverte ou non par
un document d'urbanisme et sans
condition de densité pour les communes
au RNU la loi exige seulement qu'elles
approuvent ou prescrivent un PLU ou une
garde communale avant août 2026 enfin le
dernier sujet particulièrement important
sur ce sujet nous pouvons compter sur un
forfait national d'artificialisation de
10000 hectares mutualisés entre les
régions couvertes par ansradettes si la
mise en place de ce côté à part pour les
projets d'intérêt national était
acquises l'identification de ces projets
et la mutilation de la consommation
d'espace en résultant ont suscité
d'Avent davantage de débats il finit le
dialogue entre président du conseil
régional conférence régionale de
gouvernance et l'État pour identifier
les projets d'envergure national devrait
prévaloir mais si besoin la commission
de concertation proposa donc un
arbitrage en cas de dépassement du
forfait national de 10 000 hectares le
surplus de consommation ne pourra en
aucun cas imputer sur l'enveloppe des
territoires parallèlement à l'examen du
texte au Parlement les négociations se
sont poursuivies avec le gouvernement
avec notamment la présentation et la
mise en consultation le 13 juin dernier
de deux projets de décret l'un sur la
nomenclature du zan l'autre sur
l'application par les stradettes nous
avons rappelé que l'intention du
législateur dans le cadre de la loi
climat et résilience était très clair la
trajectoire permettant d'aboutir aux
objectifs d'usane ainsi que leur
déclinaisons territoriale figure au
titre des objectifs du stradet et donc
dans un rapport prise en compte or en
publiant le décret 2022 763 le
gouvernement avait contourné
cette intervention cette intention en
prévoyant qu'en matière de lutte contre
l'artificialisation le fascicule du sera
d'être devait comprendre les règles
territorialisés avec des cibles
chiffrées nous sommes toujours opposés à
cette logique verticale estimant que le
stradet devait demeurant document
stratégique et non de venir prescriptif
nous avons trouvé un accord avec le
gouvernement sur ce point le caractère
obligatoire de ces cibles
chiffrées formulées dans le décret de
juin dernier a été supprimé redonnant
ainsi de la souplesse aux régions dans
la territorisation de leurs objectifs
nous ne pouvons que saluer tous ces
efforts de négociation qui ont permis
d'obtenir un texte cohérent nous
espérons qu'il permettra de mise en
œuvre d'usage de manière apaisée et
respectueuse des particularités locales
pour ce faire deux sujets toutefois
restent en suspens la question de
l'accompagnement des élus est celle du
financement il faudra en effet renforcer
l'ingénierie crée des adaptations
fiscales aider à accompagner à
identifier la rapidité les effacements
de friches sur ces points le groupe
socialiste défendent plusieurs années
successives des propositions lors des
débats budgétaires conscient que
l'élaboration d'une carte communale peut
représenter un coup important pour une
petite commune nous demandons à nouveau
à ce qu'une ligne budgétaire ISO dédiée
ainsi que le renforcement de
l'accompagnement technique nous y
ajouterons des aides supplémentaires à
la rénovation du bâti ancien des
communes rurales c'est un point auquel
nous tenons tout particulièrement
puisqu'il s'inscrit totalement dans les
objectifs de sobriété sans pour autant
compromettre le développement des
territoires donc si les débats ont été
parfois vif nous sommes satisfaits
d'avoir pu aboutir sur un texte de
compromis équilibré pour cette raison
nous voterons naturellement en faveur
des conclusions de cette CMP
merci chers collègues
la parole est à madame Cécile Cu Kerman
pour le groupe CRCE pour 5 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues notre volonté
commune ici au Sénat était de clarifier
les objectifs d'usage en facilitant leur
mise en œuvre sans en faire une entrave
supplémentaire à la libre administration
des collectivités territoriales il
fallait garantir aux élus une meilleure
prise en compte et déséquilibres
existants ce que le mode de calcul des
objectifs d'usane ne permettait pas
initialement il fallait veiller à ne pas
fragiliser le territoire et faire comme
si la situation actuelle et
l'aménagement du territoire
d'aujourd'hui était parfait alors qu'il
y a des déséquilibres flagrant qui
pénalise nos concitoyens nos élus il
fallait aussi agir clairement en faveur
de la transition écologique pour
garantir une pérennité des espaces
naturels agricoles forestiers dont nous
ne pourrons pas nous passer il y a
urgence à agir pour la perméabilité des
sols les nappes phréatiques la
biodiversité contre le réchauffement
climatique qui se fait de plus en plus
sentir
alors cette loi telle que proposait
aujourd'hui ne va certainement pas
résoudre complètement le grand enjeu qui
est celui de la ménagement mais nous
allons garantir un droit à l'hectare et
c'est important cependant madame la
ministre sans moyens supplémentaire pour
traiter les friches pour installer de
nouveaux services publics sans un
rééquilibrage des investissements
réalisés sur notre territoire que ce
soit en matière de logement en matière
d'infrastructures d'entreprises de
transport vous aurez beau avoir des
droits à construire il ne se construira
rien je le relevais en première lecture
67% des intercommunalités déclarent
avoir déjà refusé des projets
d'implantation économique ou subit des
déménagements d'entreprises par manque
de fonciers selon les céréma
alors l'enjeu de rapprocher le
consommateur du producteur le salarié de
son lieu de travail mieux aménager pour
moins polluer demeure et demeurera
l'enjeu de la présomption de la
transition écologique demeure également
un impératif je l'ai dit notamment pour
préserver les sols entre ces deux ces
deux enjeux il y a cette équilibre celui
de facilité l'implantation de projet
d'intérêt généraux pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'écologie sans égalité sans prise
en compte des réalités sociales et
géographiques de nos territoires dans
leur diversité le choix que nous faisons
doit permettre à toutes et tous
d'habiter une planète vivable et d'y
vivre dignement pour cela nous devons
donner la place qui est la leur au
collectivités c'est-à-dire celle d'avoir
le droit de décider d'aménager d'ajuster
et pas seulement de subir
parallèlement il faudra des moyens en
renforçant notamment le fond vert par un
plan d'investissement sans précédent et
là nous en sommes loin beaucoup trop
loin il se dit même que ce fond serait
amputé des sommes nécessaires à la
reconstruction des bâtiments endommagés
lors des récentes émeutes et
collectivités la transition écologique
subiront alors la double peine et je ne
rappellerai pas ici les enjeux chers à
mon collègue Cédric Vial sur le FCTVA
compte 212 et la capacité
qu'avait plutôt les collectivités
précédemment à bénéficié du
remboursement du FCTVA dans
l'aménagement des espaces naturels et la
renaturation des sols nos travaux ne
seront donc certainement pas juridiques
l'alpha et l'oméga de la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique mais ils seront
un outil que nous avons su au Sénat
rendre mieux efficace nous avons
conservé un droit au projet d'un hectare
pour toutes les communes et ce droit
madame la ministre doit demeurer
communal
nous avons permis d'accueillir des
grands projets non d'écouter jusqu'à 10
000 hectares toutes ces décisions sont
suivies débattues par une conférence
régionale qui tiendra compte de la
diversité des collectivités dans sa
composition et je veux le préciser
également ici un droit de proposition
pour les régions mais aussi un droit de
contestation le droit de préemption le
droit de surseoir à statuer pour
permettre une meilleure maîtrise du
foncier est aussi un progrès et un
pouvoir supplémentaire obtenu pour les
élus locaux enfin nous avons accordé 6
mois supplémentaires dans la déclinaison
des objectifs du zan il demeure des
vigilances tout d'abord et cela a été
rappelé celle sur le devenir du décompte
des bâtiments agricoles qui aujourd'hui
si rien n'est fait pénaliseront demain
nombre de nos communes dans leur
capacités à construire il demeure une
vigilance celle qui sera de relever 4
défis intrinsèquement lié
celui de la souveraineté climatique
celui de la réindustrialisation de notre
pays celui de la souveraineté
alimentaire et celui du logement
ce texte parce qu'il remet en cause une
approche dogmatique et qu'il permet de
construire une approche pragmatique fera
date dans sa capacité demain à repenser
la manière d'aménager notre territoire
je ne doute pas d'ailleurs que nous nous
reverrons bien plus vite que nous le
pensons sur ces enjeux notre groupe
votre a ce texte et monsieur le
Président si vous permettez en 10
secondes supplémentaires de saluer le
travail de notre présidente de notre
rapporteur ils ont su je crois nous
permettre d'atteindre un consensus qui
attiré par le haut et qui n'a pas nivelé
par le bas tout en respectant les
sensibilités de chacune et de chacun ici
au Sénat dans une république ou parfois
le débat politique est si fragilisé je
crois madame la ministre que ça doit
être une méthode de travail et en tout
cas j'en fais le vœu qui doit nous aider
demain à repenser la politique dans
notre pays en tout cas je les remercie
très sincèrement merci chers collègues
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame à la présidente
Valérie Letard pour le groupe Union
centriste pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur cher
Jean-Baptiste chers collègues chers amis
avant toute chose avant d'en venir en
fond je voudrais vous remercier et
remercier tout particulièrement notre
rapporteur et amis Jean-Baptiste blanc
pour le travail sans relâche et
passionné accompli durant ces derniers
mois cher Jean-Baptiste
je voudrais aussi remercier l'ensemble
des membres de la commission des
affaires de la Commission transpartizane
de notre commission spéciale alors je
vais les citer il y avait Cécile il y
avait Christian Sonia Daphné Jean-Claude
Elsa pourquoi parce que comme la
rappeler Cécile il y a quelques instants
c'est un travail transpartisan qui est
la marque de ce Sénat qui est un erreur
vendron on sait encore faire ça
travailler sur des idées sur des valeurs
qui sont celles de la défense de
l'intérêt général et des territoires au
bénéfice du plus grand nombre et ben je
crois qu'au travers de ce texte c'est
vraiment ce qu'on a su formuler au
travers de ce qui nous réunit pour
aboutir positivement aujourd'hui
alors merci aussi bien sûr à notre
président de la commission des affaires
économiques qui de son côté Sophie prima
a toujours alerté et toujours fait en
sorte qu'on ne perd pas non plus cette
boussole merci à nos administrateurs
Sébastien notre secrétaire général ambre
ambre qui a beaucoup travaillé mais
aussi Arnaud Thierry je voudrais aussi
associer Coralie parce que Coralie elle
a démarré l'aventure et il y a pas
d'histoire sans nos administrateurs
c'est un tandem les élus et les
administrateurs et aussi il faut dire
combien ils ont joué leur rôle
alors oui monsieur le ministre
Christophe Béchu et vous-même la
ministre vous avez aussi contribué à
cette solution à ce résultat positif
encore une fois pour nos territoires
celui et bien d'accompagner le long et
compliqué travail de compromis qu'il
faut trouver pour arriver à une solution
qui permette en même temps d'être
respectueux d'une ambition climatique
que nous appelons de nos vœux mais de le
faire comme Cécile tu l'as dit et je le
partage faire en sorte que nos
collectivités puissent agir et non subir
parce que la loi de décentralisation
c'est bien ça qu'elle dit au bénéfice de
chacun de la spécificité de nos
territoires agir en partenariat avec
l'État mais ne pas être des agents qui
n'ont plus le droit de penser et
d'imaginer le meilleur pour leur
concitoyens et voilà ce que nous avons
tous ensemble défendu dans nos richesses
avec nos diversités avec nos
sensibilités différentes et là vraiment
c'est pour moi une grande victoire et
c'est bien cette victoire nous
achèverons de remporter aujourd'hui
c'est une avancée pour nos territoires
c'est une avancée vers quelque chose de
plus praticable d'acceptable et de
soutenable nous avons réussi à trouver
effectivement un texte dont on aurait
peut-être espéré les uns et les autres
plus mais en tout cas équilibré qui
permet la mise en œuvre de l'ambition
essentielle de la sobriété foncière tout
en la rendant encore une fois soutenable
pour nos collectivités les points
cardinaux de notre proposition de loi
figure dans le texte final il s'agit de
la garantie communale dont nous avons
d'ailleurs conservé
inutile amélioration introduite par
l'Assemblée à savoir la possibilité de
mutualiser cet hectares au sein d'une
intercommunalité avec l'accord de la
commune et puis comme ça a été dit
Madame la ministry faudra que vous soyez
garant et attentif à ce que nos communes
puissent bénéficier d'un soutien
financier quand on leur demandera
d'aller vers un document d'urbanisme car
sinon et bien il ne faut pas attendre
deux qui sont en capacité
améliorer la qualité de leur travail
sans leur donne pas les moyens qui vont
avec il faut y bien évidemment
reconnaître au travers de ce texte nous
avons apporté des solutions sur si à
statuer droit de préemption élargie dès
qu'on de l'artificialisation en aide dès
2021 et pas 2031 nous redonnons de la
souplesse aux élus dans l'application
des objectifs de réduction de
l'artificialisation dans leur territoire
ces outils étaient déjà tellement
attendus le point sur lequel nous avons
buté le plus durement c'est celui de
l'incidence des projets d'envergure
nationale ou européenne or c'est la
pierre angulaire de tous les défis vous
le savez bien il ne s'agissait pas d'un
subterfuge pour renoncer aux objectifs
de réduction de l'artificialisation
fixée par la loi climat résilience mais
bien juste de faire en sorte que
trajectoire de décarbonation les trois
textes qui sont arrivés ensuite ENR
nucléaires ou encore industrie verte et
bien évidemment sobriété foncière se
rejoignent c'était bien ça notre
ambition faire que l'objectif
intermédiaire de 203 bien puissent
rejoindre tous ces aspects les solutions
monsieur le rapporteur vous les avez
rappelé alors aujourd'hui évidemment et
bien il nous faut penser que ce que vous
nous venons d'accomplir est une première
étape nécessaire mais pas suffisante je
ne ferai plus là pour vous accompagner
dans cette aventure mais le PLF 2024 les
textes qui vont devenir arriver
budgétaires et législatif feront la
réussite ou l'échec du zan car pas des
ânes sans moyens pas de zan sans
reconquête de l'Autriche et donc les
ambitions financières l'ingénierie et
bien sûr encore une fois faire en sorte
et toujours que l'État quand il va
mettre tout ça en oeuvre n'oublie pas
qu'il a besoin de sa deuxième jambe les
collectivités on fait ensemble les uns
avec les autres pas les uns qui disent
aux autres ce qu'ils doivent faire c'est
le seul message c'est soyons tous
solidaire jouons l'intérêt général
travaillons avec l'État mais que l'État
ne travaille pas à la place des
collectivités mais avec les
collectivités tous ensemble ont réussir
à se parier mais chers collègues je vous
souhaite plein de bonnes choses pour la
suite et voilà bon un petit pincement au
cœur mais cela
il ne s'y est pas à la présidence de
joindre de ce joint aux applaudissements
de l'hémicycle pour autant je ressens la
même chose que ce que les collègues
viennent d'exprimer et je suis moi aussi
très émue de cette dernière intervention
[Applaudissements]
oh pardon mais vous êtes monsieur
Corbisez vous étiez là vous n'avez pas
attendu que je vous appelle pour venir
donc la parole est un Jean-Pierre
corbizet effectivement ce serait
malheureux qu'aux Journal officiel on ne
sache pas qui est intervenu merci madame
la présidente Madame la président de la
mission de contrôle je ne me rapporte à
ma chère collègues que l'erreur
administrative aujourd'hui du Sénat de
me faire parler en dernier alors je que
je pense que la dernière prise de parole
aurait dû effectivement être Valérie
l'État
j'ai eu l'occasion mais je suis un
collègue de dire à plusieurs reprises de
cette tribune mais il est bon de le
rappeler une nouvelle fois dans des pèse
à ceux qui questionnent encore l'utilité
du Sénat la proposition de loi dont nous
achons l'examen aujourd'hui
l'illustration parfaite est tangibles du
rôle qui est le nôtre être un
contrepoids l'Assemblée nationale et la
majorité gouvernementale et agir pour un
rééquilibrage des politiques ou
dispositifs décidés
territoriales le dispositif desan quand
bien même nous partageons sa philosophie
et son objectif de préservation de notre
environnement a été imposée sans réelle
concertation avec les premiers concernés
que sont les élus locaux ces modalités
de mise en oeuvre telles que prévu
initialement par le gouvernement ils ont
inquiété crispé même le Sénat s'en est
saisi pour corriger le tir et faire en
sorte de tenir compte de la spécificité
des territoires inéquitablement impacté
par le zan merci donc à nos collègues
Valérie Létard et Jean-Baptiste blanc
d'avoir pris cette initiative et selon
le travail transpartisan réalisé par
notre assemblée sur ce texte
pour le reste nous savons tous le
bicamérisme c'est l'art du compromis
celui avec nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale à titre principal de ce point
de vue le taxi fut de la CMP préserve
certains apports de la Haute Assemblée
j'y reviendrai compromis avec le
gouvernement par ailleurs se texte
présentant la particularité d'avoir
amené le ministre à proposer au sénateur
de retirer certaines dispositions de la
PPL pour les traiter par la voie
réglementaire avec la promesse de la
société très étroitement les sénateurs à
l'élaboration des décrets ainsi que les
associations d'élus nous resterons donc
les vigie de nos élus locaux le
compromis c'est aussi la confiance nos
collègues ont accepté de transier avec
le gouvernement pour certains articles
les choses semblent acquises puisque le
ministre s'est engagé en direct par
téléphone en pleine CMP de reprendre
inextino les articles retirés du texte
d'autres éléments pourraient s'avérer
plus complexes à appréhender dans la
sérénité l'image des questions telles
que le nom prescritivité du sera dette
ou l'élaboration de la nomenclature des
surfaces considérées comme
artificialisée ou non classification
essentielle et qu'il focalise la tension
des élus locaux l'avenir nous dira s'ils
ont eu raison de faire le pari de la
confiance sur le fond du texte qui nous
est soumis aujourd'hui nous devons de
saluer la préservation de certains
acquis sur lequel le Seigneur ne
souhaitait pas renoncer ce fameux
hectares communal un logement du délai
de mise en conformité des documents la
combustion équilibrée de la conférence
régionale la mutation interrégionale de
l'artificialisation induite par les
grands projets et leurs sorties des
comptes au-delà des 10000 hectares même
si nous étions nombreux à souhaiter une
sortie totale la suppression de la
condition de densité pour la garantie
communale conditions silicone de
l'acceptabilité du dispositif par les
maires des petites communes nous pouvons
nous féliciter des outils concrets que
le texte mobilise pour permettre aux
élus d'être accompagné dans l'attein des
objectifs de la loi climat et résilience
comptabilisation en aide de
l'articulation dès la première période
décennale droit de préemption urbain
élargie notamment en cas de renaturation
sur scie à statué lorsqu'un projet pour
mettre en péril lateinte des objectifs
de réduction de l'articulation à
l'horizon 2031 et un très spécifique
pour les bâtiments agricoles quelques
regrets néanmoins que n'ayant pas pu
aller au bout des attentes des mers
concernant la détermination des périmées
d'identification la prise en compte du
recul du trait de côte pas très
satisfaisant ou encore le traitement des
dents creuses et des friches à titre
individuel pour arrêter interpellé par
de nombreux mères je me félicite malgré
tout du travail conduit du résultat
obtenu au terme de ce parcours
législatif je pense que le Sénat était à
la hauteur de ces missions et de ce rôle
de représentation des collectivités et
de défense de leur intérêt notre groupe
le soutiendra et je terminerai par un
message un peu particulier à l'intention
madame la présidente de cette mission
plus jeune mère du Nord-Pas-de-Calais en
1995 pour les villes de 1000 habitants
vous est accueilli madame la secrétaire
d'État à l'époque la solidarité sur ma
commune plus tard nous avons travaillé
ensemble sous votre président de la
commission aménagement du territoire au
niveau du cancer régional ou à l'EPF
nous avons partagé ensemble cette même
passion pour l'aménagement du territoire
au sein de l'ère métropolitaine de Lille
nous avons œuvré ensemble et accueilli
ensemble chez Bernard Cazeneuve sur ma
commune encore pour leur nouveau du
bassin minier je voulais vous retrouver
ici en 2017 à ce moment un vrai bonheur
toujours pour débattre ensemble de
l'aménagement du territoire du
canalseneuve Europe du logement minier
vous nous quittez comme il a la barrière
tu t'en vas
ne restez pas trop loin ma chère Valérie
nous aurons encore besoin j'aurai encore
besoin de votre œil à Visé je vous
remercie
bien la commission spéciale a de
demander un scrutin public sur les
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire donc nous allons procéder au
vote le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin est clos
temps 343 exprimer 327 pour 326 contre 1
madame la ministre vous souhaitez vous
exprimer avant que nous passions au
texte suivant
merci Madame la présidence je voulais
juste dire quelques mots au nom du
Président de la République nom de la
première ministre et au nom du
gouvernement on a bien sûr de Christophe
Béchu remerciez pour votre entièreté de
votre travail sénatorial cher Valérie
vous remercier tout particulièrement
pour votre compétence votre persévérance
votre authenticité votre sincérité dans
votre engagement et vous féliciter pour
votre contribution à ce vote à la quasi
unanimité merci Valérie
madame la ministre si vous voulez bien
laisser la place à votre successeur au
banc du gouvernement
sans que nous ayons besoin de suspendre
des t'installer à sa place nous allons
donc pouvoir examiner les conclusions de
la commission mix paritaire chargée
d'élaborer un texte sur les dispositions
restent en discussion du projet de loi
relatif à la restitution des biens
culturels culturels ayant fait l'objet
de spoliation dans le contexte des
persécutions antisémites perpétrées
entre 1933 et 1945 la parole est un
Béatrice Gosselin rapporte pour le Sénat
de la commission mixte paritaire
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues c'est une nouvelle
fois avec une grande émotion que
j'interviens à la tribune alors que nous
nous apprêtons je l'espère à adopter
définitivement le projet de loi relatif
à la restitution des biens culturels
liés
les débats intervenus jusqu'ici dans
chacune des deux Chambres du Parlement
ont démontré combien ce texte était
attendu même si nous sommes conscients
que les crimes de la Shoah sont
irréparables nous savons aussi qu'il est
de notre devoir de faire oeuvre de
justice et d'humanité en proposant des
solutions justes et équitables
conformément au principe de Washington
les spoliations de bien culturels ont
porté atteinte aux Juifs d'Europe dans
leur dignité
leur culture leur histoire et leur
identité
elles ne peuvent être dissociées de la
politique
d'extermination pardon conduite pendant
cette période c'est pourquoi la
restitution des biens qui m'appartient
qui appartient aux collections publiques
m'apparaît impérieuse parce que je crois
qu'elle fait partie intégrante du
travail de mémoire et de justice
vis-à-vis de la joie
du projet de loi en première lecture au
Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale a
permis de mettre en évidence le
consensus politique qui se dégage autour
de ce texte
lors de l'examen du premier texte de
restitution de bienselier il y a un an
et demi nous deux chambres c'était
d'ailleurs exprimé en faveur de
l'adoption d'un cadre général permettant
de simplifier et d'accélérer des
restitutions de bien spolier appartenant
collection publique le texte n'a que peu
évolué par rapport à celui que nous
avions adopté en première lecture
l'Assemblée nationale n'a remis en cause
ni l'architecture de la procédure de
restitution qui figurait dans le projet
de loi initiale à laquelle nous avions
souscrit ni des apports du Sénat
destinés en renforcer la transparence et
en faciliter la bonne application
ces modifications ont visé à approfondir
le travail que nous avions amorcé et
sécurisé encore davantage la procédure
de restitution
ainsi plusieurs dentelles ont permis
d'apporter une réponse à des
préoccupations que nous avions exprimé
en séance le texte prévoit désormais la
possibilité de solliciter le concours de
l'État pour octroyer une compensation
financière ou victime ou à leur ayant
droit en échange du maintien avec le
raccord du bien dans la collection
publique
si l'Assemblée nationale a souhaité que
le rapport destiné à informer le
Parlement des restitutions opérées ne
soient finalement transmis que selon un
rythme bisannuel elle en a étendu en
contrepartie le chant a un certain
nombre de données qualitatives relatives
à la recherche de provenance qui peuvent
nous satisfaire la commission de la
culture est convaincue que
l'intensification du travail de
recherche de provenance est la clé de
voûte des restitutions à venir en
demandant au gouvernement de nous
fournir des éléments sur son action pour
contribuer à son développement nous
l'incitons à aller de l'avant dans cette
direction ce qui nous empêchera pas de
nous montrer évidemment extrêmement
vigilant sur ces points lors de l'examen
chaque année des projets de loi de
finances
comme nous en première lecture
l'Assemblée nationale s'est montrée
sensible à mieux reconnaître la
responsabilité propre du régime de Vichy
dans les persécutions antisémites
la formule à laquelle elle est parvenue
pour caractériser les autorités
responsables apparaît comme un bon
compromis en évoquant l'État français
entre le 10 juillet 1940 et le 24 août
1944 soit entre la date du vote des
pleins pouvoirs à Philippe Pétain et la
date de publication du dernier journal
officiel de l'État français le
législateur reconnaît clairement avec ce
texte la responsabilité de l'État
pendant cette période c'est-à-dire celle
des autorités politiques comme de
l'administration sans revenir en arrière
par rapport à la reconnaissance de la
responsabilité de l'État français faite
par le Président de la République
Jacques Chirac en 1995
dans ces conditions la commission mixte
paritaire s'est contentée de strict
modifications rédactionnelle J'espère de
tout cœur que ce texte recueillera votre
approbation unanime je crois devoir
insister sur le fait que